well first and foremost congratulations
on being part of survivor season 41 it's
incredible you did such a great job how
are you feeling today obviously this
isn't what you had hoped for but what
are the emotions you're feeling after uh
last night
well
i would say i am happy as every other
day
because as i've been telling the loves
that i get or received from my fans
and it's out there so
you can't read those without smiling so
if you can if everybody can put smile on
my face which is i always always smile
right so what else you want i'm like
again
you know only one player going to be
winning this game no matter what that we
have been seeing that for 20 years now
or 21 years so
no regret and
i enjoyed it and
i really appreciate what i had and what
i have done and the way i played
yeah i mean listen people dream of
getting on this show just being a part
of season 41 like tell me as a fan this
must have been a complete total dream
come true
absolutely no question about it it's not
100 200
true so i've been dreaming to be
on the show forget about winning
movements and everything that's later
right so
that is for me the biggest winning part
to get to grew up in a tiny village
never been to america stop watching
learning language or the english from
watching the season you know and
learning all jefferson's the words that
he throw out you know that like my
you know so
and
i'm on the show
what else you want
right exactly listen you came in smiling
you left smiling that just shows the
type of person you are you have this
positivity that just radiates um even
though you were blindsided how
comfortable were you going at the tribal
council because it came off as a true
shock to viewers oh that was a classic
blind side that survey should be played
you know
so uh i was that is the only day that i
felt very comfortable and that was the
day i went and saw it on jerry
you know so one survivor
not
100
trust anyone right oh
you have to when you start feeling that
then you start
stop thinking everything else right so
when you feel like
i enjoy the feelings like
being underdog or being on the bottom
because in that way you play really hard
and to know what's going on around you
know whoever talks you're reading the
lips are you reading and listening to
everybody when you're sleeping you're
sleeping like elephant you know like
you're
you're not really sleeping you know just
listening even in snore they can mumble
some stuff you know so that is a game
you play right but when you feel
comfortable but at the
at some point you have to have some
trust in someone
else's hand right so again that
what make this game really beautiful and
it's been successful too so if i can be
part of
that
group
i'm very happy
yeah they say expect the unexpected and
there was lots of unexpected things this
season that is for sure but would you
say that heather deserves an oscar for
her performance of pretending she was
going home yesterday when she knew a
blind side was on the horizon
well definitely she knows that she
played a good show uh like she put a
good show but at the same time at the
end
all right the the cries at the uwa
island was
she put a show but at the tribal council
when she cried uh uh
and erica cried because i tear i may
play my idol for me
that cry wasn't really a good cry that
wasn't the show over there
because you know if i play that idol and
she knows she's going home
all right so everything else was a good
cry it's a classic blind side and and
i you know i'm
i'm sad but the same time there was a
good way to go instead of just being on
the chopping block and go the next hour
no they know that
i'm a bigger threat over there nobody
can win if i'm sitting on final three
forget about final three even if if i go
to final four nobody can make fire with
me
[Laughter]
you're right you're right listen you
have the you you had the unique
experience of being voted out and then
immediately walking over to the jury
what was it like to switch your game
from player to jury in the matter of you
know minutes
well that is the good thing about me i
would say uh i'm not perfect but i'm
very adaptive
because i know when i came to the game
only one person going to
win right so that is why even for future
survivors you play your game
like there is no other day
if you if if you get worried out or wore
it off
make sure to build your or have a thick
skin to face right front of you whatever
it sees so switch it and enjoy the jury
you're so funny i love chatting with you
your background growing up in sri lanka
um do you it was really a help for the
survival side of things did you expect
to be seen as a threat because of it
no because i was expecting that to be
threat but the same time when i found
out my tribe has no clue
what to do over there in terms of
building a shelter finding food and they
i'm like they don't know the leaves even
what leaves like can i use this to
wipe my bum
is it poison i'm like no don't touch
that you know so everybody and they will
become can i use this one can i do this
one can i do that i was like a book over
there for them you know like okay then i
know even though they tried to get me
vote me out like
but the same time they have a fear
like no
then what i'm going to eat there is no
rice
nobody knows how to get coconut even you
know so uh and matter of fact i show my
friend danny how to pick coconut it take
me only one minute for him it took more
than an hour i showed the wrong way so i
drained his energy that way
smart guy smart guy you could have led
them in so many wrong directions that's
for sure there were so many twists on
this season of survivor more than in
recent years for sure what do you think
really shook the castaways most to their
core
the hunger
the hunger because when you hear that
everybody planning okay we're gonna uh
maybe many of uh survivor contestants
they're always practicing eating rice
before they go so they can get used to
it right so with that car but when you
when you find out there is no rice and
also
it's it's a
the fast pace of the game
it's never stopped if it's keep moving
if you
sleep for a minute something happened
you know then and again i mean like
previous seasons like yeah even though
we went back to normal or back to basics
to build a shelter they had a rope or
whatever
but we never had so everything is like
i'm using the natural resources that i
can i know with what i did so at the end
even i was probably able to build the
best and bigger shelter for the android
drive even after the merch they came
still we were able to sleep all on the
same uh
platform so imagine how big of a shelter
i remember lyanna came and said that oh
wow that is like hilton out here
and and they had like they were talking
right before a challenge one day then
like uh
jeff asked the team how is going like
food wise now like
they said like
you have nasir what else you want lubu
[Laughter]
you went home with an idol uh where is
the idol now i did i don't have it in my
because they they hold on to the idols
now so
yeah because after ghost island i think
you know
they used previously played idols
to change the curse or something maybe
there is a new twist coming out out
there do you want to find nasir's
blindsided idol
you go to that journey you know
so let me ask you this this is a
two-part question because the answers
can be very different okay so first of
all who do you want to win season 41 of
survivor and the second part is who do
you think will win season 41 well who do
you want to win which is not going to
happen it's supposed to be nasir it goes
right answer that is the right answer
all right but
who are you going to win uh
it's hard to determine
yet
because if nasir can get blindsided is
idle in his pocket
anything can happen
uh
because
all
all of them are
in a way they are very solid players
over there
does that make sense so
anything can happen so i need at least a
couple more weeks to determine who's
going
and uh you know so just to just to yeah
yeah so it's gonna be fun and uh it is
it is an amazing season already and uh
you know so it's gonna be even
i don't wanna say even better because
nasir is no longer there right so it's
gonna be good
last question because people loved you
so much on this show would you come back
and do it again sometime if i receive a
call now i will cancel the next
appointment and i'll take a flight and
then
there we go well we hope to see you
again on the show you did such a
incredible job playing the game congrats
to you and it's been a blast catching up
with you thank you so much for your time
today thank you so much
you